a artist in my head i deal with that a
lot you know i'm saying i can't lie
about that um than going through therapy
and then finally being in a good head
space still struggling some days um so
yeah therapy man i feel like uh it's
something that a lot of people are
comfortable i feel like it's starting to
become normalized i love this gender
like my generation i'm starting to
realize we're so amazing just as far as
like
i look around all my homies as great
parents when i remember us being younger
none of us had our dads and now we like
over like we just overcompensating for
what we didn't have you know i'm saying
we super like dads now um
and so yeah even with therapy like my
home is just starting to be open to it
black and brown community starting to be
open to it so i think it's dope what is
uh what was there anything that like
kind of was like your tipping point
where like i need to go talk to somebody
type [ __ ] for me my feelings would just
hurt i was just crying i was tired of
crying and the opportunity was presented
to me from lvrn um because you know they
care about the artist's mental health so
shout out to them and i didn't really
want to do it at first it felt like
homework some days it still feel like
class you know what i'm saying because
yeah because i've been to therapy they
sometimes you get like exercises
like yeah do this do this and uh we'll
meet next week yeah exactly so having to
do stuff when you leave and it's like
man i just want to come here and not
have to deal with it when i get out of
therapy so
it's still a struggle you know what i'm
saying but i'm starting to notice the
benefits of it just like i'm more
patient more open to people and i
understand where they're coming from and
stuff like you find yourself like
practicing [ __ ] you learn like in real
time you're like oh this is
yeah just like um i get tested still and
the way i'm able to approach the
situation now and i just react out of
like
uh anger or feel like i'm getting
attacked when somebody give me their
opinion on something and i know in the
past that's been my problem is always
feeling attacked when somebody go
against my way of thinking